I was watching your can press conference
and something you said Harrison caught
my ear you emphasized how you've never
seen actors give to each other quite
like they did on the set of this film so
can you each tell me about a time when
another actor in this Ensemble gave you
exactly what you needed on a day on the
set well Antonio Banderas would do the
Puss in Boots impression whenever you
asked him
like that
didn't help me much
clearly helped her get through a day or
two
well you helped me every day
that
I think that you know we had a really
good script uh and and we have wonderful
actors that have chosen to play these
parts and we're delighted to have all of
them
uh lucky to have all of them
but but to to go back and remember
something really honest and specific
about about how how a day went is
I I can't do it maybe she's younger
brighter mind than mine she can do it
but to me it's it's just there's an
atmosphere that Jim uh
help create
that is really uh conducive to people
wanting to to
do their best work
and I think everybody in this film I
mean was extraordinary
and so uh
but I had a lot of scenes with Phoebe
and I was
one of the best things you can do uh for
a fellow actor
is to surprise them
not you know not
in terms of improvisation or anything
but to be to have them really be there
have them really be present
really
emotionally involved in the scene
is
it's just I it's a pure joy
and I had a lot of that in this movie I
literally just heard someone else say
that exact same thing about you I just
spoke to Krista Miller and she said that
is how you operate on the set of
shrinking
wow that's nice thank you all right I'm
gonna make you both turn compliments
towards yourselves now Phoebe Frio is
reading a quote from uh James and our
press notes that I loved he described
your ability as an actor as unlimited so
can you give me an example of a time on
this set when you even impressed
yourself you couldn't you didn't think
you could do something but you pulled it
off oh gosh I don't know if I've ever
felt that in my entire life
um
I think the physical side of this film
was really surprising and exciting and
the faith that Jim and everyone had that
I could do that and running it nobody
thought you could do it
but then but then she went ahead and did
it but then
it needs me to do it well well well
is exactly relative term not slick but
well luckily it was important that it
wasn't slick that I didn't have to be
slick that we were messy and it was fun
to
mess things up like the characters do so
I think I think it was really that that
surprised me the most and I think there
probably were times when I'd sort of
fall off a wall or something and be like
I know that a green screen opportunity
here is climbing a rope and I guarantee
you I will not be slick I will be clumsy
and I will Channel you okay this is
absolutely perfect
um I'll end with my my cheesiest
question of All For You Harrison it's
something I've I've come to ask a lot
lately because I'm a big believer that
nobody in this industry tells themselves
good job nearly enough so whether it's
something you accomplish on this film or
anything in your career what is
something that you could look back on
and say to yourself like damn I am proud
of what I did there
I can't do that
I just uh constitutionally can't do that
there are many people out there I messed
up look a million things for you look
I'm grateful for every day for the
opportunity to do what we do
and every day is a surprise every day
I'm grateful for the for the for the
emotional exercise that I get
and that's and and so
it has it's it's not about me it's about
us it's about what's going on in the in
the room and believe me there's nothing
more important than the than the reality
of of a person bringing themselves to to
a situation openly
with with uh emotional clarity
and and and wit
and uh and I I'm I am I love what all
the other actors do I don't I can't
think about myself that way that's why I
asked that question though nobody will
say good I can't do it to myself so it
feels like an unfair question to ask to
others well thank you very much that was
a beautiful answer though and thank you
for sharing all that with us because I
could not live my life without these
movies that you all make so thank you
thank you so much